several men start to get pregnant so
they create a community to feel united
as a minority and talk about their
problems today on cinema recapped i'll
show you he's expecting from netflix
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
chapter one the series begins with a man
named kentaro hiyama who works in a very
important advertising agency one day
they tell him to create a new project
for the company
after work kintaro goes to see a woman
named aki who is an editor and his
girlfriend they give each other some
affection and then they start watching a
news item on television about some cases
of pregnant men kintaro tells aki that
he doesn't think that's true and also
adds the children are just a nuisance
since he has seen that those who have
children don't prosper in life
a couple of days later kintaro presents
his project to the company it's about
showing more diversity such as showing
people of different skin colors with the
intention of creating a social impact so
they can gain more audience
the company agrees to continue this
project so kontaro decides to celebrate
that night with his colleagues and they
also take the opportunity to celebrate
his birthday the next day kintaro goes
to the agency to work on the project but
suddenly begins to feel very sick and
decides to go to the hospital after
several tests they tell him that he's
pregnant kentaro believes it's a mistake
so he decides to buy himself a pregnancy
test which confirms that he's pregnant
chapter 2
kenturo tries to continue his normal
life but he has several problems that
prevent him from working such as nausea
dizziness pain
and even milk beginning to come out of
his breasts meanwhile aki has a life
full of work so she doesn't have time to
have children and even considers the
idea of having surgery to never get
pregnant kenturo goes to the hospital
asking to remove the baby the doctors
tell him that it can have such an
operation but that he must bring a
document where both the father and the
mother say they agree kentaro talks to
aki and tells her that he's pregnant and
that he's sure she is the mother but
that he doesn't want to have the baby so
he asks her to sign the papers aki tells
him that she agrees with him but just
when he was going to sign the agreement
kentaro gets dizzy and vomits all over
the paper they don't sign anything the
next day aki goes to see a friend and
tells her about the pregnancy the friend
tries to convince her to have the baby
since she believes it's a blessing
later in a cafe aki sees kantaro again
ostensibly to sign the agreement but
this time aki tells him that she does
want to have the baby kintaro replies
that she is being selfish and isn't
thinking about what he's going to go
through aki ends up signing the paper
and kintaro goes to his work however
when he arrives they tell him that due
to his strange behavior his project has
been assigned to someone else
chapter 3 kentaro goes to the hospital
to schedule the day for the intervention
and while there he meets another man who
is also pregnant they go to dinner to
talk about their experiences and the man
explains to kintaro how excited he is to
have a baby which makes kintaro question
whether to have the intervention or not
the agency where kintaro works presents
the finished project to their investors
but they reject the proposal saying that
the project is boring and that
everything on it has already been seen
before at that moment kintaro decides to
propose that they add pregnant men to
the project and tells them that they can
use him as a model revealing to them
that he is going to have a baby the
investors are surprised and quickly
accept the proposal saying that it is
something unique and that it will surely
attract a lot of attention and at that
moment the agency decides to promote
cantaru back as project leader kentaro
talks to aki and tells her that he's
going to have the baby haki replies that
she's going to help him with everything
later kentaro talks to his mom on the
phone to tell her the news she's worried
because she tells him that he's going to
get a lot of criticism for being a man
and pregnant days later kintaro is used
as a model for the project and the
photos of him pregnant end up being
published everywhere chapter four
kintaro's photos go viral and receive
several comments some of them are funny
others surprising and still others begin
to show support for pregnant men
meanwhile aki continues her work but at
the same time she begins to do a
personal project in which she writes
what it's like to be the partner of a
pregnant man one day kintaro goes to a
checkup at the hospital accompanied by
aki and there they're told that the baby
is going to be a boy kintaro stays to
see his friend that he met at the
hospital who's also pregnant they decide
to create a page where pregnant men can
share their experiences and people can
support them several pregnant men begin
to join that page kenturo decides to
organize a meeting in a restaurant and
several men attend they all become fast
friends and give each other advice on
another day kintaro and aki go out for a
walk and kintaro tells her that they
should start thinking about getting
married and buying a home so they can
raise the baby however aki tells him
that she doesn't want to get married at
that moment kintara receives a call
telling him that his pregnant friend is
in the hospital he and daki go there
immediately and when they arrive they
tell him that his friend lost his baby
kenturo speaks to his friend's wife and
she tells him that she's relieved the
baby was not born since she believes
that society was going to make fun of
him kintaro begins to think that perhaps
society will not accept his son and
remembering that aki does not want to
marry him he decides to break up with
her to raise the child alone
chapter 5 aki goes to a family event and
as soon as she arrives her parents begin
to pressure her telling her that she
should get a man and have children
kantaru goes to work and in a meeting
they tell him that they already have a
long-term project to show his life after
his baby is born kintaro feels pressured
by the project and also begins to feel
sentimental about the pregnancy however
the boss and his colleagues try to calm
him down although we see that they only
do it because it generates benefits for
the company aki goes to a meeting with
friends and there she hears a lot of bad
comments about pregnant men she starts
thinking about what kantaro must be
going through augie decides to see her
parents again and this time she tells
them that she has a boyfriend and that
he is pregnant with her baby then she
decides to call kintaro and convinces
him to start a family without getting
married kintaro accepts and tells her
that he's very happy because they're
going to start a family since he only
had his mother when he was a child his
father died when he was very young at
that very moment a man approaches
kantaro and tells him that he is his
father
chapter six
kintaro asks his mother if that man is
really his father and she has no choice
but to confess that it is true and
explains that she lied about him having
died because that man abandoned her
later kintaro lets his father stay in
his home and he tells him that he was
the one who gave birth to him so we see
that he too was a pregnant man the
father tells him about the experiences
he had and then asked him to do a
project together to create items for
pregnant men kenturo decides to tell his
mother about that project but his mom
tells him not to do business with his
father since she knows him to be just a
scammer kintaro goes to talk to his
father about canceling the project but
he realizes that his father has already
met with several pregnant men and has
convinced them to invest in the business
meanwhile aki receives a very good job
offer but for that she must relocate far
away aki calls kintaro to try to
convince him to move together but
kintaro refuses because he has a job
there the next day kintaro finds out
that his father scammed the pregnant men
and that he left with all the money
they'd put into the project news of this
goes viral and people start saying that
kintaro is also a scammer just like his
father
chapter seven kintaro beats his friend
who was pregnant and they both talk
about how difficult it is to be a
pregnant man then kintaro decides to
look for his father and ask for
explanations about why he left meanwhile
kintaro's mom and daki talk about what
it's like to be the partner of a
pregnant man and both say that it's hard
to get over the fact that they're not
the ones giving birth to the baby
kintaro finds his father and confronts
him for having left he replies that he
did that because he suffered a lot in
the past when he was pregnant since back
then society was tougher and they made a
lot of fun of him kentaro's father
apologizes to him and returns the money
he stole telling him not to follow in
his footsteps and to live life no matter
what they say later kintaro returns home
and talks to aki she tells him that
she's going to accept the job offer
which is only for two years saying that
she'll try to visit him from time to
time a couple of days later kintaro goes
to a conference to explain what happened
with his father while aki goes to the
airport to take her work trip then
kintaro explains that he had nothing to
do with the fraud and takes the
opportunity to say how much pregnant men
suffer from bad comments made by people
tentaro finishes his speech and just at
that moment falls to the ground feeling
a lot of pain aki is watching what's
happening on tv and she decides to
cancel her trip and help quintaro
chapter 8. they take kintaro to the
hospital where his mother father and aki
visit him after a few hours the nurses
tell them that kintaro has had the baby
and that everything went well
both sets of grandparents go to see
kintaro and the baby and they take a
picture to remember that moment a couple
of days later we see that kontaro and
aki are taking care of the baby together
aki continues with her work and kontaro
continues talking with his friends from
the community of pregnant men one day
kintaro and aki go to dinner and aki
tells him that she was offered the job
abroad again but this time she's not
going to accept however kintaro tells
her that it is not necessary for her to
stay since she has to do whatever makes
her happy kenturo also tells her that he
will continue working in the agency and
that he will fight for more comforts to
be offered to parents so they can take
their children to work some months later
we see that hockey did accept the job
offer and that she went to live abroad
while kontaro stayed in the city but
both maintain communication and take
good care of their baby on tv we see
that the news has normalized pregnant
ben and that people respect them more
the end if you liked the video please
leave a like and subscribe to continue
receiving recaps the best netflix series
thanks for watching